abone ol
Ne
varmış Mustafa Ertuğrul 25 yaşındayım ve
çok mutlu oldum bir Sosyal Gelişim var
buradan hayatımda yapmak zorunda olduğu
şeyleri nasıl büyük bir tutkuya
heyecanlı dönüştürdüm ama buradayım ve
asla hayatım
değişti bunlardan bahsedeceğim
ve
biz o
[Müzik]
O çok sorulardan ve batında Aslında
hayatında bir şeyleri gelir birleştire
biliyormuşum buna insanlar bu benzer
birleştiriyoruz birşeyleri bu
üniversiteye kadar çok başarısız bir
çocuk ve bulunduğum okuduğum dönemde
Eskişehir'de de bir tane falan kafamı
çıkarmaya mezun oldu ve
hayatımın geri kalanı daha sonra
birleştirerek
yapmam gerekir yapmaya çalıştığım şey
göreve ödev duygusu çağrıştırdı herkese
geldiği gibi bana da sıkıcı gelir de o
işe koyulma ya kendini ikna etmeye
çalışır ta ki bir şeyler o duyguları ben
de tutkuya dönüştüğü gün Aslında ben bir
şeyleri başardığım fark etmeye başladım
Nasıl oluyor da bir anda onca şey
yapılacak dönüşebiliyor
bu video olabilir bence Aslında şöyle
bir oldu e
inandığım ve kendi içinde harekete
geçirmeye Çalıştım o iş özelliği Ne o
görevi üzerindeki duyguları tutkuya
dönüştüğünde bir şeylere Gerçekten ona
dakikalarını harcama onun gözlerine bir
şeyler yapmaya çalışacağım hiçbir olması
gereken bir yapı halini aldı ve o gün
bozulmadan bugün kendin etmeye
çalışmadan yapmam gereken her şeyi
yapmaya başladı nasıl oldu size bir ara
anlatayım hayatında bir şeylerden biri
bir şeyler de
[Alkış]
çok
seviyorsunuz Bunu niye bakmasaydı
devrimi bazı gibi olsada kullanıyoruz
Bunun için ayrı geliyordu yapıyorduk ya
[Müzik]
değil tamam hazırlanmış buz gibi kırmızı
karşıladı
beyaz çarşaf yıldızında Sırrı doğru
geriye doğru Yazdığınız ve bir yılın
yorgunluğunu atacağınız
başladı Daha sonrasında hiç vakit
kaybetmeden hemen al
[Müzik]
O yüzden çekirdeksiz olmasına karar
yaşıyorduk aileyle o tatili böyle birşey
anlatmıyorum Ve sonunda Diyorum ki
bu hayalini bu tarihli Hayatının geri
kalan bütün dönemleri yaşayabileceği bir
şey
hiçbir şekilde bu satmaya çalışmadım
Sadece bu hikaye bazen geçirmek
bu Eylül'ün önündeki en önemli ve en
kolay ve belki de bedava yapabileceğiniz
için o tarz yaşatmadan o yatağa
yatırmadan o karpuz yedirmeden hayalini
bularak anlatabilirdim bunu başardığım
gün hayatında birçok şey değişti ve o
gün o 7233 yine satamadım çok fazla
Hayat konuştuk güldü ama o
[Müzik]
de bundan sonra nasıl yaşaması
gerektiğini gösterecek tavsiyeyi
vermeliydi öyle de o 22 günden sonra
güneşin satış yapar ve hayatımda
vermeyecek alamadım kadar boşa yapalım
oranın tam satıcılığından bir olmuştu
sonra Hayatımda bu duyguları harekete
geçirmek altın ürettiğine kendime
kazandıktan sonra bu birçok farklı
tecrübelerle birçok farklı sektörde
kendini topladıktan sonra ve o zaman
üniversitedeki sınıftayız
başladı ve o
eve
gidiyorum iki yazında
içerikte ve İsviçre'de çok ilginç
tecrübeleri dışında çok güzel ve biri
girişimcilik dünyasına bakmayacağım
insanlarla tanıştık ve bu tanışmanın
sonrasında Türkiye'ye dönük bir şeyler
yapmak istiyorum bir şeyleri başarmak
istiyorum
Bugün bundan önce bu şekilde
girişimi Aslında asıl o
[Müzik]
da tam olarak Aslında bu sorunu çözmek
için ortaya çıkan ve ilk duyduğumda
karşı tarafa ne yaptığını çok net
anlatan amacını anlatan ve ilk aşaması
destekleme arzusu uyandıran bir girişim
olduğunu fark ettik bundan dört yıl
önceki o
[Müzik]
çok küçük bir şarkıları de Ağzı güzel
zaten böyle gitmeyecekler
koyup ve anlatmaya başladık
o
kadın üreticilerden alıyoruz Sabancı
Üniversitesi öğrencileri olarak
yapıyoruz biz gençler olarak girişinizi
bu yönde bulduk sonunda
sonra düşündüm ki
[Müzik]
değil Örneğin karşınızdaki
müşterilerimizin kullanıcılarının
duyularını harekete geçirmek gerektiğini
anlatmak oldum şükür yaptığımız için
arkasında 400'den fazla kadın ve fazla
çalışarak 100 milyon liralık bir değere
dönüştürdük bu gazoz atmak için gittiğim
ülke başta olmak üzere binlerce üye ol
[Müzik]
o dönecek olursak
başarısız başlayan yaşam serüvenini
yapmaktan çok sıkıldım yapmak konusunda
kendini ikna etmeye çalıştım bir yaşam
serüvenine
yakaladığım duyguları harekete geçirmek
kavramında bugün çok değerli bir noktaya
gelir Bunun çok bedava yakıt olduğuna
inanıyorum şimdi doğru olursa ve
karşımıza Gerçekten bunu
anlatabileceğimiz bir alıcı varsa
hepsini bir varsa her
şey
olur Hayallerde onları harekete geçirin
ikinci önemli nokta burada Bunu da
bir şeyler birleşmiş öyle bugün
olduğumuz ile anlatmıyorsa çok güzel
gelecekler çok yeni gelecekler sürekli
olabilir ve renkten vazgeçmeyi devam et
sıcak suda dediği gibi Aslında noktaları
baktığımızda ileri doğru
birleştiremezsiniz hep bunlar geriye
doğru birleşir ve Bence yaşamımızı
istediğiniz noktaları istediğimiz
noktaya götürecek Rotayı kurmak için de
bu noktaları sağlam şekilde gelir
bırakmak soğanı
konuşmanın sonuna geldim ve Son bir şey
söyleyeceğim
geçtiğimiz Temmuz ayında isterseniz daha
aniden bir kalp kaybettim ve o gün
hayatındaki en hızlı duyguları en
yaşadığım belki ama bugün
geçmişte o kadar fazla güzel ya
bir
girişimci olan alışında o kadar bırakmış
ki içinde duyguları harekete geçirme
sonucunda çok iyi kullanabildiğimiz için
o elde edenlerden şekilde dedim ve Bazen
hayatta
Bu sadece güzel duygulara geçirmem
gerekiyor onlarla baş etmek zorunda
kalıyoruz çok daha kötüleri ile diğer
arada olmak zorundayız binlerce insanın
ruh haliyle binlerce insanın bugün var
olduğu yaşadığı yaşantıyı değişik
yıllardan boş ederek yaşamak zorundayız
böyle bir dünya için Hadi şimdi tüm
duyularınızı harekete geçirin ve
duygularımıza o
[Alkış]